neben mir ist fraport vorholt sie sind
dem tod förmlich von der schippe
gesprungen sie waren in ischgl skilaufen
und haben sich damit dem profit mit dem
corona virus infiziert haben
mit 19 bekommen erzählen sie wie es
ihnen jetzt geht und was ich hier jetzt
in der median klinik in heiligendamm
machen
also ich bekomme jetzt hier eine rede
weil ich habe 13 tage im koma gelegen
und als ich aufgewacht bin war ich auf
null also was meine kondition anbelangt
von der lunge her körperlich hatte ich
sieben kilo muskelmasse verloren und
konnte also am anfang gar nicht stehen
da haben die schon in der klinik wo ich
halt lag die haben wir auch schon ein
bisschen starthilfe gegeben mit physio
und ich durfte dann gott sei dank hier
nach heiligendamm in die rehaklinik und
hier habe ich jetzt schon quantensprung
hinter mir obwohl ich gerade mal eine
knappe woche hier bin kann ich jetzt
schon treppensteigen
mir geht es von der atmung her viel viel
besser meine ausdauer ist schon
wesentlich weiter als vorher
also ich fühlte mich wie eine 80 jährige
frau herbold waren sie hatten sie eine
vorerkrankung waren sie einen eine
risikopatientin vorher schon oder wie
würden sie sich vor der krankheit
beschreiben
also ich bin 54 jahre alt ich hatte
überhaupt keine vorerkrankung ich habe
ganz normal sport gemacht
ich ernähre mich nicht zu ungesund und
wie gesagt wir kamen ja aus einem
skiurlaub also dass man fährt auch kein
ski wenn man irgendwelche
lungenkrankheiten hat das geht gar nicht
aufgrund der höhe schon nach ostern habe
ich jetzt so eine welle erlebt in der
bevölkerung dass sie sagen mensch wir
wollen ganz schnell wieder zurück in die
normalität wir wollen wieder an den
arbeitsplatz wir wollen wieder einkaufen
macht doch endlich die läden wieder auf
verstehen sie die leute und was raten
sie den leuten aus ihrer ganz
persönlichen perspektive also ich kann
die leute total verstehen weil die
meisten kennen ja noch nicht mal
jemanden der im entferntesten positiver
das ist für die meisten gar nicht
greifbar das war vor meiner erkrankung
bei mir nicht anders das war ganz weit
weg
und wenn man dann selber so schwer
erkrankt ist und im koma gelegen hat und
das mit gemacht hat dass ich mitgemacht
habe auch meine familie die ja sehr
mitgelitten hat und es wirklich nicht
klar war ob ich das überlebe sehe ich
das sehr gespalten ich wie gesagt ich
kann das total verstehen
man muss eben sehr sehr diszipliniert
sein anderthalb meter abstand halten
ich bin auch für die massen pflicht in
sämtlichen bundesländern ich kann auch
nicht verstehen dass der föderalismus
greift und nicht der bund
ich bin auch der meinung dass man zum
beispiel draußen sport ohne
körperkontakt sehr wohl erlauben kann
während kontaktsport komplett verboten
bleiben muss bis wir einen impfstoff
haben
eventuell kann das tatsächlich bis
anfang 2000 21 dauern
meine letzte frage haben sie denn sich
als risikopatientin gesehen hatten sie
angst vor dem virus oder haben sie das
eigentlich so ein bisschen auf die
leichte schulter genommen
ich hab das absolut auf die leichte
schulter genommen ich habe da keinen
gedanken daran verschwendet weil es hieß
er erstmals wird trifft nur ältere ich
bin noch keine 80 ich wie gesagt ich bin
ich bin auch kein risiko patient gewesen
also und ich habe gedacht na gut wenn es
christ dann ist das ihr vielleicht wie
eine grippe
das war's aber dass sich daran sterben
könnten und es mich so schwer erwischt
dass hätte im leben nicht gedacht
niemals